bienvenido a la presentación de
multiplicación de expresiones dejame
poner un problema dicen multiplica x 2 x
2 x x + 3 x 3 puede parecer un problema
extraño pero en realidad ya sabes
hacerlo simplemente hay que aplicar la
ley distributiva mira si tuviéramos a x
x 3
entonces pues aplicando la ley
distributiva simplemente nos quedaría a
x x + deja pongolle o de naranja primero
entonces sería a por x + a por 3 a por 3
se ve un poco raro pero lo podemos poner
como 3a pero bueno el chiste es que este
a multiplica a cada uno de estos
términos estamos haciendo lo mismo aquí
solo que ahora a es x + 2 es toda la
expresión x + 2 entonces vamos a ver
cómo nos quedaría nos quedaría x 2 x x
más x2
x 3 x 3
entonces parece un poco complicado pero
no lo es simplemente tenemos que darnos
cuenta que estamos haciendo lo mismo que
de este lado pero ahora el x + 2 juega
el papel de a bueno ya que hicimos este
primer paso el problema ya es muy
directo otra vez tenemos que aplicar la
ley distributiva distributiva con cada
uno de estos términos entonces que nos
quedaría déjame quedarme nada más con el
color verde nos quedaría x x x x
cuadrada luego 2 x x 2 x + 2 x más 3 x x
es 3x y luego más dos por tres que es 6
ya casi terminamos ahora hay que juntar
estos términos que son términos
similares porque tienen la misma
potencia de x y entonces nos quedaría x
al cuadrado más 2 + 3 son 5 x + 6 muy
bien entonces ahí está este problema y
simplemente la idea es distribuir este x
+ 2 en cada uno de estos términos y
después ya se hace muy directo vamos a
hacer otros problemas más
entonces imagínate que queremos
multiplicar 5 x + 9 5 x + 9 con 4 x 2 4
x 2 mismísima idea distribuimos el 5 x +
9 5 x + 9 primero con este 4 x x 4 x
y luego hay que sumar el 5 x + 9 5 x 9 x
el menos 2 x menos 2 vamos a ver qué nos
queda me pasó a color verde 5 x x 4 x lo
hacemos aquí abajito 5 x x 4 x pues esto
es lo mismo que 5 x 4 x x x x
qué es 20 x cuadradas y 5 x 4 es 20 x x
x x cuadrada entonces nos queda 20 x
cuadrada más 4 x 9 36 36 x más menos 2
entonces aquí va con menos entonces es
menos 2 por 5 es menos 10 x menos 2 por
9 menos 10 y 8 va muy bien simplificamos
juntando términos similares y nos quedan
20 x cuadrada 36
10 26 más 26 26 x menos 12 muy bien
vamos a hacer un ejemplo más
déjame pasar aquí abajo voy a cambiar de
colores para para que no esté tan
monótono entonces siguiente problema 2 x
más 2 x más x 3 x + 2
creo que ya vimos de qué se trata ya
nada más voy a usar un color entonces
voy a distribuir este 2x más pero voy a
poner primero ahora estos para variar
tantito entonces distribuyendo me queda
3 x x 2 x más que es este por este más
12 12 x 2 x más y sale ok en
desarrollamos este y este 3 x x 2 x pues
3 por 12 6 x x x x cuadrada más 3 veces
x x ya que se puede escribir como 3x y
aquí sí es lo mismo que x x + 2 x 2 x 2
x 2 3 4 y por xx más 2 cuadradas
dossieres dulce cuadradas
muy bien ahora este se podrá simplificar
pues si x y xy es exactamente lo mismo
entonces podemos juntar estos dos
términos y nos queda 6x cuadrada más 3
más 7x y juntando estos dos tres cuatro
y siete más dos que cuadrada o bien
también pudimos haberlo escrito poniendo
la aie primero o sea como 6x cuadrada
más 7 y x + 2 y cuadrada ba es
exactamente lo mismo espero que esta
idea no te confundan pero bueno vamos a
hacer un último problema rápidamente
porque éste está interesante y dice
tenemos que encontrar 2 x + 2
2 x 2 al cuadrado ahora hay que resistir
la tentación de elevar cada uno de estos
al cuadrado y sumarlos porque si no no
estaríamos haciendo las cosas bien va
entonces para hacer las cosas bien
tenemos que reescribir éste cuadrado
como producto de dos cosas algo al
cuadrado es ese algo 2 x + 2 por sí
mismo 2 x + 2
entonces mismísima idea distribuimos
este 2x + 2 en cada uno de estos
términos y nos quedan 2 x x 2 x 2 2 x x
2 x + 2 más 2 veces 2 x + 2
vamos a simplificar bueno desarrollar y
ahorita simplificamos 2x x 2 x 2 x 2 es
4 x x x x cuadrada 2 x x x 2 4 x 4 x + 2
x 2 x es 4 x 4 x y finalmente hay que
sumar 2 x 2 que es 4 muy bien
simplificamos podemos juntar estos dos
términos nos quedaría 4x cuadrada más 8
x + 4 ok entonces 4 x cuadrada más 8 x +
4 es 2 x + 2 al cuadrado creo que con
estos ejemplos ya estás listo para
intentar algunos problemas de
multiplicar expresiones nivel 1